hey remember when fauci shut the whole
world down for two years over a virus
that he assured us did not escape from a
lab in wuhan which he assured us did not
conduct gain of function research which
he assured us he had not funded with u.s
taxpayer dollars
until we found out that all that stuff
actually did happen and fauci had been
lying about everything you remember that
well senator rand paul remembers which
is why yesterday he held the first ever
congressional hearing on gain of
function research which confirmed what
people who had been paying attention
have known for more than a year
dr fauci funded the same sort of
research
at the same chinese laboratory that was
at the center of the outbreak
of the virus
what are the implications of dr fauci's
continued
blatant dishonesty regarding nih's
funding of gain of function research in
wuhan
i stand by my statement the statements
made on repeated occasions
to the public to the present
policymakers
by the naya director
dr fauci have been untruthful i do not
understand why those statements are
being made because they are demonstrably
false
demonstrably false
fouchy lied our political order died and
that little napoleon in a lab coat
thinks that he can get away with it
whether he does or does not
rests entirely with congressional
republicans which means it is incumbent
upon all of you to call your congressmen
tell them not to squish and send a
message to the legions of power mad
technocrats that we will not let them
upend our entire way of life without
consequence i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from mike hancho
who says it's amazing at this point that
our white house press briefings aren't
held in chinese with english subtitles
you make such a great point i'm shocked
forget about subtitles we don't do
subtitles anymore for some reason a
couple of years ago the libs brought
back the sign language people we don't
need the sign language people anymore
because now we have subtitles but for
whatever reason they brought them back
so we would have needed
chinese to english
uh
hand gesture people uh before i go
further down that line and get myself in
a whole lot of politically incorrect
trouble we'll just leave it at that it's
true the white house is carrying water
for the chinese there's no question
about it they've been doing it for years
now they've been doing it through the
the kovid pandemic they've been doing it
on economic matters they've been doing
it now as china aggresses in taiwan
because china makes all our stuff and
they own a trillion dollars of our debt
and he who pays the piper calls the tune
now when i when i want to sit back
and listen to pipes and enjoy beautiful
tunes i don't know i don't you know what
i like for dinner i like good ranchers
right now head on over to
goodranchers.com i love good ranchers
because the food is absolutely delicious
and it's american beef and it's just
magnificent i eat it probably three
times a week but
in addition to that the second reason i
love these guys
is they're really good guys back to
school season is upon us while many
american kids are excited to get back
into the classroom some others are not
because these children don't know where
their meals will be coming from this
semester
that's why good ranchers has made it
their mission to donate 100 000 high
quality meals to kids facing food
insecurity and malnourishment this fall
semester for every box ordered through
the month of august
good ranchers will donate a nutritious
meal to a child in need help them reach
their goal of 100 000 donated meals by
ordering your box today
goodranchers.com knowles they are an
award-winning food delivery service
ships 100 american meat and seafood
right to your door
they were just named the best food
subscription service earlier this year i
totally agree with that they are the
fastest growing meat company in america
the quality is off the charts right now
use my code knowles to get thirty
dollars off your order plus free
shipping your purchase furthers their
mission to donate 100 000 high quality
meals to children in need great cause
that everyone should rally behind
goodranchers.com knowles head on over
use code knowles today when you place
your order and let's get these guys some
help to hit their goal
speaking of science and politics
there's a new report out this was
brought to my attention by edmund smirk
one of my favorite twitter accounts
there's a new report out i just saw this
in barry weiss's
website barry weiss the
heterodox liberal journalist whose sub
stack is far more credible and respected
than the new york times or the
washington post
the headline is court documents reveal
canada's travel ban had no scientific
basis
in the days leading up to the mandate
transportation officials were
frantically looking for a rationale for
it they came up short this has been true
of a lot of a lot of political decisions
during covid
the scientific basis just wasn't really
there you think about the mask orders
you think about the six feet orders you
think about vaccine mandates and the
rationale for those things just didn't
really exist we were told if you wear
the mask it won't stop the spread at all
and then we were told you have to wear
the mask it'll totally stop the spread
we were told
we have to stand six feet apart then we
were told that that just was a number
plucked out of thin air we were told if
you get the vaccine you won't catch
covet or spread it then we found out
that the vaccines did absolutely nothing
to stop you from catching or spreading
coping so yes there was no scientific
basis and conservatives are pouncing
on this this sort of a headline
there are no scientific basis this was
all just politics
but actually
the conservative response to this sort
of a thing is
good
this should be politics
it should be a political decision
when you shut down a country for
whatever reason for a virus or for a
national security threat or
or just because everyone wants a break
on a tuesday afternoon that is a that is
a political issue and it should be
decided through politics
it's not it's not actually conservative
to say well we just need the experts and
the lab coats and the technocrats to
give us all the data and the statistics
and then that will make the decision for
us about how we run our lives and keep
our businesses open or shut them down or
close the churches or go to school or
not that's not conservative at all
that's liberal technocracy that's taking
power away from the people that's
surrendering our political rights
a lot of times during covid you would
have people point out and a lot of
conservatives would say these decisions
are political they're not scientific
right they are political the problem
with the decisions is not that they're
political political decisions are
supposed to be political the problem
with the decisions is that they were
stupid the problem with the decisions is
that they were contrary to the american
traditional way of life and they were
contrary to a good and flourishing
society the problem with the the
decision to keep the pot dispensaries
open during covet but to shut down the
churches is not that the decision wasn't
scientific it's that the decision was
radical and leftist and anti-christian
and anti-american
and our political order should be
oriented to be more pro-christian and
pro-tradition and pro-family and
pro-business and pro-traditional way of
life
and
anti-drugs and blm riots
and and the like
that that's the problem
it's politics is is good it's good when
people engage in politics especially in
a self-government
you got to move past the procedural
question and you got to get to the
substance what kind of politics are we
pushing you know who gets this ron
desantis ron desantis totally gets this
down in florida that's why desantis
right now is calling for a new kind of
law
that would allow doctors who trans
little kids
to be sued
these very young kids getting
gender affirming care what they don't
tell you what that is is they're
actually giving very young girls double
mastectomies they want to castrate these
young boys that's wrong and so we've
stood up and said both from the health
and children well-being perspective you
know you don't disfigure
10 12 13 year old kids
based on gender dysphoria 80 of it
resolves anyways by the time they get
older so why would you be doing this i
think these doctors need to get sued for
what's happening i'm sorry
they absolutely do so this is a good
line for desantis he's also testing out
now this idea he's
he's saying hey what do you think if we
made it such that you could sue doctors
for transiting the kids and it's getting
some applause they'll see how it plays
in the local press and then i hope
governor desantis will actually turn
this idea into a law
and what the libs and the technocrats
are going to say is excuse me governor
desantis where's your medical degree you
don't even have a lab coat or a
stethoscope you're not even a genius
medical physician like dr rachel levine
or dr fauci or you know all these people
who are just completely insane and wrong
about everything you're not even one of
those medical doctors uh you're right
you're right should be desantis's answer
you're right i'm not a medical doctor i
don't have a medical degree and you know
what i don't need one
i'm the governor
and that when we're talking about
political matters and the law and
government and how we run our society
and how we treat poor little kids who
are being victimized by creeps and
perverts
being a governor is much more important
than being some stupid medical doctor
working for the public health
establishment transiting the kids and
killing the babies and locking us all
down for two years that's the answer
oh yeah okay you've got your
statistics and your studies and okay
that's fine
by the way all of the actual credible
studies on on these sorts of issues are
on our side there is no credible medical
study that says that boys are actually
secretly girls that doesn't exist
okay so the the libs are
are though they claim the mantle of
science are obviously very unscientific
but that's actually beside the point we
live in self-government and the people
of florida have the right to say don't
trans the kids i don't care what your
stupid medical doctors and your
establishment says it doesn't doesn't
matter to me we're not going to let you
trans the kids and if you try to do it
we're going to sue you and ideally we
would throw you in jail or banish you to
saint helena along with dr fauci and all
the rest of you power mad technocrats
that's the right answer
and we and you can have the scientific
conversation too
you can have the scientific conversation
and say well actually you see the girl
has the two x chromosomes and the boy is
the xy chromosome and actually if you
put the kids on puberty blockers too
early then that's going to give them
osteoporosis and actually it's going to
give them and it's going to sterilize
them that's true that's all true it's
all it's all pertinent
but those are secondary matters
the the first most important aspect here
is our liberty not the individual
liberty to mutilate yourself or to
mutilate your kid even
the higher political liberty to say this
is the kind of society we want to live
in
we're going to have a normal definition
of man and a normal definition a woman
and we're not going to let perverts and
radicals
castrate our children and that's that
and you can whine about it and you can
cry about it if you don't like it move
to california but we're not doing it in
florida
if and desantis obviously gets this he's
testing the waters i think if he goes
all the way on that kind of message
it's going to serve him
very very well
in a 2024 presidential election if he
indeed runs for president
now speaking of kids
and science and politics there is a
little bit of bad news just came out of
kansas we had
one of the election days we have a
number of election days this year
because it's a midterm election year
different states hold different
primaries and elections on different
days we had a little bit of a
disappointment in kansas there was a
pro-life amendment
that was put up as a referendum the
people were voting on this amendment and
the pro-life amendment failed and
there's some lessons here for pro-life
activists conservatives more broadly
into why it failed and how we can avoid
failure in the future
so the pro-life amendment in kansas
was the first
statewide referendum on abortion since
the dobbs decision came down and
overruled roe v wade and overruled
planned parenthood vkc and got rid of
the
national constitutional right to an
abortion that doesn't actually exist
the the referendum was a little bit
weird the kansas state constitution
includes a right to abortion
the
referendum that just failed was to
replace the
pro-abortion amendment the right to an
abortion in the state constitution with
a right to life
so a a constitutional ban on abortion in
kansas and it failed
unfortunately it failed by 17 percentage
points so it was not particularly close
and
uh the question is why did it fail how
did it feel i don't know i don't have
the text of the amendment in front of me
uh
the the
title of the the amendment was the value
them both amendment
but
the issue of abortion is not simply
black and white
there can be nuance here and don't
forget we're called to be wise as
serpents and innocent as doves so one
way that the pro-life amendment perhaps
could have been framed
is
not even as a pro-life amendment but as
a get this crazy abortion thing out of
our state constitution amendment in fact
the way that you just saw the pro-life
issue play out at the supreme court the
supreme court didn't come down and say
okay now we have a national right to
life the supreme court came down and
said it's not in the constitution make
your own laws
had this been more of a legislative
matter rather than a referendum for an
amendment to the constitution
that might have worked out a little bit
better for pro-lifers or it's hard to
tell with kansas
we're going to see how this play you
generally you think of kansas as a
fairly republican state fairly
conservative place we will see how this
plays out throughout the rest of the
country but it's an important reminder
because i think conservatives are
feeling a little uh
a little like the wind is at our sales
right now and in many ways it is
but it's not going to be a simple
victory after victory after victory
after victory we're gonna have to be
clever we're gonna have to tailor our
message to different states we're gonna
have to
know that what works in virginia is not
gonna work necessarily in texas it's not
going to work necessarily in florida
it's not going to work necessarily in
kansas we've got to be clever and take
the greatest wins that we can possibly
get without letting perfect get in the
way of good speaking of life
and
death and little babies in the womb
chrissy teigen
i don't really know what chrissy teigen
does but she is all over social media
and she's frequently in the headlines
chrissy teigen is pregnant again
through ivf after she had a miscarriage
and i do remember when the story of her
miscarriage came out
so chrissy teigen
suffered a late miscarriage it's very
very sad and she mourned the laws of her
child as a child and this was very very
sad and now
what was it uh
some months later at least she
or some years later i guess this was
actually a couple years ago she has
become pregnant again and now she's very
excited she said the last few years have
been a blur of emotions to say the least
but joy has filled our home and hearts
again
one billion shots later in the leg
lately as you see because she's going
through ivf we have another one on the
way
i have a great deal of sympathy for
chrissy teigen
i i can't even really imagine how
terrible it is to have a miscarriage
that late
especially that like to have any
miscarriage really but especially that
late when you've you've invested so much
emotionally and physically into this
baby and then the baby is dies in the
womb it's very very sad and i'm i'm
happy for her that she will get to have
a baby hopefully hopefully she'll get to
have a baby
the question then you gotta ask yourself
especially if you're a supporter of
abortion
first question why was chrissy teigen so
sad when she had a miscarriage
the pro-abortion people tell us that's a
clump of cells that's morally irrelevant
there's no b it's no big deal it's it's
a parasite get rid of it
get rid of it and then go have a party
for how fun your abortion was
well if that's true
then chrissy teigen shouldn't be sad
then we should think chrissy teigen's
really weird for being sad over her
miscarriage why are you why are you so
sad it was just a clump of cells it was
just a random morally irrelevant
we have to grapple with that
only one of those two things can be true
only
it can either be the case that this is a
meaningless clump of cells or it's
really sad that chrissy teigen had the
miscarriage obviously the latter is true
and chrissy tegan is sad because that's
a life in the womb
okay so we should discard the
pro-abortion talking points and it's not
like chrissy teigen is some right-wing
rock-ribbed conservative she's a a
cultural figure and i assume she's on
the left so the left should
take a minute and think about that okay
the value of chrissy teigen's child does
not just come because she likes the
child or she wants to acknowledge the
child child the the value has to come
from the child intrinsically but then
there's another harder question which is
if all that is true if chrissy teigen
is right to be sad over her miscarriage
it is because babies are babies from the
moment they are made not just from the
moment of birth not just at
eight months and 29 days
but babies or babies from the very
beginning
and if babies or babies from the very
beginning ivf is not morally acceptable
and this is a hard message and i know
there are a lot of conservatives who
support ivf and i know there are a lot
of even pro not maybe not a lot but
there are a number of pro-lifers who
support ivf
and i know part of the reason for that
is people have benefited personally from
ivf
and people say well my child was was
conceived through ivf are you telling me
my child shouldn't exist no
sir i'm certainly not saying that it's
wonderful that your child exists
the child has value the value of a child
is not determined by the way that the
child was conceived this this is why we
don't think we should just kill people
who are conceived through rape
and and i've got a podcast out right now
called the choosing life podcast where
you we talk to people who survive
abortions where uh
you hear this throughout the pro-life
movement people who are conceived
through rape say they'll confront
pro-abortion activists they'll say do
you think that i should be killed just
because no of course not the way a child
is conceived does not determine the
value of that child but
likewise it doesn't justify rape and it
doesn't justify
methods that are immoral good ends do
not justify immoral means and in the
case of ivf it's really hard to argue
that it's morally acceptable because ivf
there are lots of moral issues with ivf
but one of them is
you create lots of human beings lots of
little embryos most of which you just
put in a freezer forever
some of which you then implant in the
woman and then sometimes if too many of
them take
the ivf process will entail abortion to
reduce the number of embryos in the womb
there are all sorts of problems but even
at the most bait and there and there are
problems actually in addition to that
through the method at which these these
embryos are conceived but even the ones
that are just in the in the freezer
you're telling me life is sacred from
the very beginning and we're all
pro-life and a person's a person no
matter how small what about the babies
in the freezer
it's not
it's not acceptable i've wracked my
brain trying to figure out a way in
which ivf can be morally justified i
can't think of it and then there's an
even broader political issue which is
that it is not a good idea i think to
put
technology to establish the domination
of technology
or any kind of power a corporate power
or a state power
to establish that domination over the
origin and destiny of human life
that seems like it could go wrong really
fast it seems like it necessarily goes
wrong
really
fast and and i think most people
on most political issues are kind of
like chrissy teigen they hold views and
they engage in behaviors that are
contradictory
chrissy teigen
so publicly mourns her child who died in
the womb because a person's a person no
matter how small and then engages in ibf
and she probably has no idea that there
is a conflict there that there's a
contradiction there but it's important
for us to talk about it especially now
that we're in a post-jobs world we've
gotten rid of roe v wade we've gotten
rid of
planned parenthood v casey we can
acknowledge that babies are actually
babies we we've moved past kindergarten
the kindergarten level of talking about
pro-life and now we need to get to the
second grade level and now we need to
get to the fourth grade level and now
because it goes a lot deeper than just
don't murder babies in the womb if you
want to get rid of our culture of death
if you want to create a culture of life
it's got to go a lot deeper than that
we've got to talk about
what what life means why life has value
where babies come from what what the
relation of the sexes are what sexuality
means to the human person the
conversation goes much much deeper and
it is no coincidence
that
the
moment in our history
that gave us abortion the 1960s is also
the moment in our history that gave us
the entire sexual revolution promiscuous
sex all sorts of weird gender ideologies
it's no coincidence that those are all
happening around the same time because
they're all
deeply related and we're not we're not
really going to solve any of those
problems individually until we have a
coherent view of what human life is and
why it ought to be
protected
now
speaking of
judges speaking of the dobbs ruling
the libs are still
screaming
crying rending their garments and
gnashing their teeth over that ruling
the most important ruling of my lifetime
maybe in the history of the united
states which we'll get to in one second
but on this very point
as you may have heard much to the dismay
of the left bill gates
moloch the sun monster
all of the i but i repeat myself
sweet little elisa and i recently
welcomed our second baby boy
you know the walshes are about to have
twins they just announced that they're
having twins babies are multiplying all
over the daily wire okay and if you
strive to be fruitful and multiply and
thwart the the libs by doing so then
look no further
than the daily wire babies collection
get yourself the no leftist tears here
bib
or the stay napping not woke onesie
because
babies and adults are best behaved when
napping not woke go to dailywire.com
shop or click the link in the
description to clothe the next
generation of daily wire plus members
today
jeremy can monetize anything you know i
mean this guy
harry's attacks us and then he just
instantly starts his own razor company
and now i have a baby not two days later
this guy starts a baby shop that's
really he's good he that guy the god
king is a very good businessman
the libs are still freaking out over the
dobbs decision they're still so
angry and carine jean-pierre
the president's spokesman white house
press secretary is
is going even further than just decrying
the decision she's going further to say
that
the supreme court's decision
and the supreme court's decision
was unconstitutional
from day one when
when the supreme court made this extreme
decision
to take away
a constitutional right
it was an unconstitutional
unconstitutional action by them a right
that was around for almost 50 years a
right that women had to make a decision
on their bodies and how they want to
start their families
what does that even mean
she's saying that she she could say that
a pro-life law that the mississippi
pro-life law was unconstitutional and
the court got the decision wrong
or she could say that roe v wade was
unconstitutional which is what the court
said but she's
she's actually saying that the court
deciding to overrule a case
is unconstitutional
does that so when the court
overruled the dred scott decision when
the court overrolled the decision that
said black people can't be citizens
was that unconstitutional of them to
overrule that decision is it it's just
unconstitutional for the court to
overrule decisions that have been around
for a long time because that's the
argument she's making here she said this
decision roe v wade had been around for
50 years almost
yeah there have been lots of bad
decisions that have gone on for a long
time that the court later reversed
you're saying it's unconstitutional for
the court to reverse it are you saying
that it's
unconstitutional for the court
to
make constitutional judgments to reverse
laws and and precedent
is because then you would have to go
back to the earliest days of the supreme
court you would have to go back to
marbury v madison and get rid of the
court's right to constitutional review
to judicial review
is that what she's saying i don't think
she's saying any of that i think she's
just saying words
and those those words don't have any
meaning
and she's just blah blah blah
and
and in the
absence of an argument she hopes that
the cacophony that is coming out of her
mouth will at least in some way resemble
an argument and fool ignorant and stupid
people into thinking that she is
actually saying something when she is
not
it's important to note when the libs
just sputter and babble and and say
nothing because it is a tell that they
have no argument
not all issues are totally black and
white sometimes really both sides can
make good points and we can try to
determine who makes better points and we
can hash it out
but when when one of the sides doesn't
even make an argument
just says
blah blah
airplane milk eggs
onesie when they just say random words
in in a way that is not grammatical and
certainly not logical or coherent then
that is a tell that they've got nothing
that that actually this is a clear issue
of course the court has the right to
overrule roe v wade i think they had an
obligation to overrule roe v wade and
it's a good decision and the libs are
just angry and what the libs are going
to do is just
neglect the
logical reasoned aspect of our politics
which is how self-government is supposed
to be conducted
and they're just going to try to to
enforce their own will
and their own interest and club their
opponents on the head without any logic
or reason or discourse involved
speaking of good court rulings
great court ruling out of san francisco
so san francisco
wanted to let illegal aliens vote
you've seen in liberal cities similar
kinds of rules
they want to let the foreign nationals
vote in the elections san francisco
judge
san francisco superior court judge
richard ulmer says no quote transcendent
law
of
tran
transcendent tran
transcendent law of california you can
tell that i've got a four-day-old
newborn and i can barely read at this
point the constitution reserves the
right to vote to a united states citizen
contrary to the san francisco ordinance
the ordinance would have allowed illegal
aliens to vote in the school board
elections
and this is this is wrong
we talked about this a little bit
yesterday
this is part of the suicide of
self-government
when you have a nation
you you have citizens of that nation and
not everyone is a citizen people who are
traveling are not citizens
last year i went to a wedding in france
i was in france i was even subject to
some of the laws of france but i i'm not
a french citizen so i didn't have
certain privileges i couldn't vote in
french elections i had to leave after a
certain period of time
there has to be if you have a nation
there has to be a distinction between
citizens and non-citizens the libs want
to destroy that distinction because the
libs want to open up our borders
because the libs believe
probably rightly that if they flood the
country with mass migration from latin
america that will give them an electoral
advantage
so
the libs believe they'll get a little
bit more power
but the cost of that power is going to
be self-government because if the
citizens don't have the right to pass
the laws for their own nation then they
don't have self-government anymore if
foreign nationals can make laws for you
then you have lost your sovereignty you
have lost your your self-government you
have lost your country and a judge even
in
liberal san francisco
recognizes that
really really we've seen similar rulings
coming up
recently but this is important because
self-government
usually does not die when the invading
army comes in and you know rapes kills
pillages and burns and salts the fields
and that's not really how it happens
self-government usually dies through
suicide through the atrophying of civic
virtue through the the ignorance of the
populace through decline in education
through through uh apathy
and through cynicism and opportunism to
try to score a few cheap political
points even at the cost of your
political order that's that's how
self-government dies and it's it's
holding on now there have been some good
moves but it's really incumbent upon
conservatives to take hold of these
opportunities that some of the judges
are giving us and say no we got to build
the wall we got to deport the the tens
of millions of illegal aliens who are in
the country we've got to button down our
election laws we've got to make sure
that there's a hard distinction between
citizens and non-citizens perhaps we
need to revisit the question of
birthright citizenship which has been
controversial throughout all of american
history and it's far from clear to me
that the constitution of the united
states provides birthright citizenship i
don't think that the people who drafted
the constitution and the amendments
really believed that they were
giving a citizenship to anyone who
happened to have a kid on this soil if i
go to france and sweet little buddy my
my new little baby happened to be born
while i was on vacation he would not
have become a citizen of france okay so
why is the united states like this why
are we interpreting our constitution
this way
we don't have all day
we don't have all the time in the world
here the political order is fraying and
the la the last few years of covid have
not helped anything they've actually
accelerated the decay so what are we
going to do to maintain our political
order speaking of san francisco even
more good news from san francisco can
you believe that it's the first time
i've ever uttered that statement
san francisco had this radical left-wing
d.a
chaisa boudin whose parents are domestic
terrorists
from the weather underground and chase
of boudin
followed in the family's footsteps and
let criminals off the hook and almost
single-handedly
plunged san francisco into just a
crime-ridden drug-filled disgusting hell
hole and he was recalled by the voters
of san francisco not the conservatives
not the republicans the liberal
left-wing voters of san francisco so now
there's a new d.a in their d.a brook
jenkins and what is brooke jenkins doing
brooke jenkins is putting the criminals
in prison brooke jenkins just revoked
more than 30 plea bargains that chase
boudin had offered to
drug peddlers
this is part of a broader policy where
she's going to go after the drug dealers
who are arrested with more than five
grams of drugs she is going to
stop them from being diverted toward
these really lib slap on the hand kind
of courts she's going to make them go
through the actual criminal justice
system she's going to impose enhanced
charges for dealers who are arrested
within a thousand feet of a school she's
going to
seek pre-trial detention for fentanyl
dealers in extreme cases so she's not
going to let these drug dealers off on
bail or bond or anything like that she's
going to force them to to sit in there
especially if they're dealing fentanyl
because it's killing people
she says she goes since 2020 nearly 1500
people have died of drug overdoses in in
part because dealers have been allowed
to operate with immunity impunity and we
we can't allow that to happen
of course now the the lesson here
this is really clever how it's happening
because brooke jenkins i assume is a
huge lib the voters of san francisco are
overwhelmingly huge libs
they kicked out chase of boudin they
brought in this lady and this lady isn't
enforcing the law against the drug
dealers how did that happen
the way it happened
politically speaking
is
they reframed who the victims are
the key to understanding this crime
issue especially the crime issue but
really a lot of areas of politics
is you've got to frame who the victim is
conservatives decry victimhood culture
victimhood culture is a part of politics
always has been always will be so rather
than throw our hands up in the air and
say we don't want to talk about victims
you've got to engage and point out who
the real victims are because what the
libs have done is they've they've
completely upended things and they've
said that the perpetrators of crimes are
the true victims and the victims had it
coming
ironically the libs who always talk
about victim blaming are the ones who
blame the victim so they say the drug
dealers the poison peddlers the people
who are killing our kids they're the
victims
they've been failed by society
those poor people they were probably
just a a poor kid got caught with a
joint in his pocket now he's going to
jail for decades which doesn't happen by
the way
nobody goes to prison for simple
possession
even if even if on paper it says people
go to prison for simple possession they
don't they go to prison because they
took plea deals down from trafficking
charges okay
no
a statistically insignificant number of
people go to jail for possession and
we're talking about simple possession
then we're talking about very serious
drugs they're very dangerous to a lot of
people okay
the these people these poor beleaguered
the
the society failed in people are poison
peddlers who work with organized crime
who
practically speaking kill kids and they
should be thrown in prison for a very
very long time we do not have an
over-incarceration problem in america
obviously not look around we got crime
going up everywhere when you've got
crime going up
by definition you don't have an over
incarceration problem you have an under
incarceration problem and it's not just
the gang bangers and it's not just the
serial killers it's the drug addicts and
it's the drug dealers and usually not
usually often they're the same people
but they're all part of the same problem
the life expectancy in the united states
has declined for the first time ever but
it's now happened several years in a row
it's declined because of deaths of
despair suicides and drug overdoses this
is a major major threat throw these
poison peddling jerks in prison and if
you don't throw away the key at least
hide the key for a very good long time
it's not just me saying this i'm a right
winger i'm a conservative it's even the
libs they get it because they're living
in these cities and they realize even
the craziest wildest libs don't want to
live in a city
with people overdosing on the streets
trying to dodge heroin needles on the
sidewalk and having their kids being
preyed upon at school when you got the
the peddlers there trying to trying to
sell their stuff
okay
they get it conservatives should get it
too just you just have to reframe and i
think accurately frame who the victims
are and who the criminals are speaking
of out of touch democrats john fetterman
john fetterman is running for senate in
pennsylvania he's the lieutenant
governor
he frames himself as a working-class
hero he dresses like a working-class
hero you know he just wears sweatsuits
and hoodies he's got a kind of a goatee
and he's like he's a real tough guy you
know
it turns out fetterman
not only is not a working-class hero
turns out fetterman
has never even really worked
a news report just came out that
fetterman
lived for
for years and years and years well into
his 40s
not by the sweat of his own brow he
lived on a five-figure allowance from
mommy and daddy
this guy
this guy who's now he's 52 years old
right now he was elected mayor of
braddock pennsylvania
2006 left that position in 2019 after he
became lieutenant governor
and his parents were just paying his way
the whole time in 2015 alone
fetterman's parents gave him 54 000
54 000 how much was your allowance when
i was a kid my allowance was one dollar
a week which i thought was generous it
was more than most of my friends and
then it got to be two dollars a week and
then i stopped getting allowance when i
turned
eight i don't know
i started working when i turned 14
and i made my own money
and
i spent my money i tried to do it
responsibly
john fetterman
got his allowance for about 40 years
longer than i ever did and he got about
uh
53 999 a year more than i did
i uh he's being framed as a hypocrite
here and he obviously is a hypocrite
he's pretending to be
a
you know hardened member of the working
class and he's not he's never worked a
day in his life he's just a trust fund
baby mommy and daddy pay his way okay
he's a hypocrite sure however however
once you get past the hypocrisy
conservatives shouldn't go too far in
this direction okay because i actually
don't mind when wealthy people enter
into politics i think often that can be
a good thing some sometimes you get
corrupt wealthy people but oftentimes
you get corrupt poor people in politics
because sometimes when people who don't
have their own money enter into politics
then they start taking handouts then
they start taking bribes then they're
susceptible to special interests think
about the greatest conservative
president certainly in my lifetime
was the richest president we've ever had
in american history was donald trump
so i don't think there should be a hard
and fast rule the founding fathers were
very very wealthy men by and large the
second wealthiest president in american
history was george washington our actual
greatest president ever
the problem with fetterman here is not
that
his family is wealthy the problem with
fetterman here is not that
having money is in itself a bad thing
the problem with fetterman here is he's
a total fraud just like his entire party
especially on working class
issues i'm thinking i'm thinking
yesterday of that new jersey elected
democrat who ran over the ubereats
bicyclist driver and then just kept on
driving didn't even slow down that's the
way the left really feels about the
working class regardless of their
fraudulent claims to the contrary
speaking of prominent 2022 candidates
meant to get to this yesterday didn't
have time
great news out of arizona the arizona
senate race blake masters
blake masters
is running for senate there we've had
him on this show
he he won the republican nomination to
represent arizona in the senate
i as a rule do not make primary
endorsements because that's not really
my job having a show i i really want to
keep an open mind and give people a fair
shake but i i was pulling for blake
masters i feel he's an excellent
candidate i think that republican
candidates around the country should
model their campaigns off of his i think
he's doing a good job and i think he
represents what people are calling the
new right
getting rid of
the stale tired
often ridiculous slogans that have
bedeviled republican politics in recent
years that have led to lots of defeats
and and shaking up those stale kind of
platitudes and engaging with politics in
a new way
one of my in a new way which is actually
just the old way
one of
my favorite moments of the master's
campaign
and it's when he really won me over
was when he put an ad out there and he
said i think that americans should be
able to raise a family on a single
income you used to be able to do that in
america you can't do that anymore a lot
of the reason you can't do that is
because of political decisions that were
made
we in politics should should
reorder our political economy such that
you can raise a family on a single
income i said preach my man
shout it from the rooftops i absolutely
absolutely
agree with that kind of thing
the old chamber of commerce republican
the old squishes the old platitudes well
i don't care what you do just leave me
alone don't raise my taxes that'll that
kind of gop politics they would shudder
at the thought
of using the government
to
reorient the political economy such that
you can raise a family on a single
income
but why plenty of political decisions
led to the moment we're at now where you
can't where people are not getting
married because they have economic fears
where people are not having kids because
they have financial worries
where people are not moving on with
their lives because they're they're
burdened with student debt and wages
have been stagnant or depressed for
decades
with a brief exception during the trump
years when they started to creep back up
now they're down again
that's a that's a real that's a real
great way of engaging in politics i'm
not throwing ronald reagan under the bus
i'm not throwing the cold war
conservatives under the bus i'm really
not they fought their battles i really
admire ronald reagan i really admire
william f buckley jr i really admire
those guys that won the cold war they
fought their battles good for them
but it's it's 20 22. folks it's the year
of our lord 2022
let ronald reagan sleep in the grave
please this poor man has he not done
enough you've got to reanimate his
corpse and have him come solve our
problems too let the man rest let the
man lie same goes for bill buckley
same goes for so many of the
conservative heroes of our past they
fought their battles they dealt with
their challenges we should deal with
ours politics is not just some eternal
thing you figure out the five bullet
points on the back of a napkin and that
there are your campaign ads for the next
25 years no
politics means applying eternal
principles to constantly changing
circumstances
the the
republicans worth their salt are the
ones
who
don't only acknowledge the first part
but acknowledge the second part as well
speaking of the new right
big vote yesterday in the u.s senate
on whether or not to sign off on
expanding nato to include finland and
sweden
by expanding nato this would obligate
the united states to defend
these countries in the event of an
attack
the vote was 95 to 1
in favor of allowing
finland and sweden into
nato senator josh hawley is the only
senator who voted
no
on letting sweden and finland in to nato
josh hawley was right
he was right
i do not think it is
necessarily a good idea to expand nato
and i am not some radical
this is not just a new trumpian crazy
idea this was the common sense of the
people who were smartest who knew the
most who were the most reasonable across
party lines during the cold war after
the berlin wall fell you had cold war
heroes
really aggressive dudes i'm thinking of
daniel patrick moynihan i'm thinking of
sam nunn i'm thinking of george kennan
who crafted the strategy of containment
to contain soviet communism all of them
said okay great we won this victory in
the cold war don't squander it by
recklessly expanding nato that's not
you think you're projecting strength but
it's going to make the world more
dangerous don't do that
that will that will make the world
much more dangerous that will raise the
possibility of war and that's what i
fear is going on here
because there is such a thing as buffer
nations
you don't necessarily want two very
powerful military alliances right up on
the border with each other okay
sometimes you want buffer nations
and the but the role of a buffer nation
is to play both sides off of one another
and give a little bit of room so that
you you don't have you don't have the
sense of an imminent security threat
right along your border a lot of what's
going on in nato right now or a lot of
what's going on i'm sorry in ukraine
right now is attributable to this
mistake had we followed george kennan's
advice sam nuns daniel patrick moynihan
had we not continued to expand nato
eastward after the fall of the berlin
wall
had we had we perceived what i think
josh hawley is rightly perceiving here
i'm not sure we would be in this problem
right now with ukraine
i'm not sure that americans necessarily
have the appetite
to
go to war for sweden or finland and i
don't think that letting sweden in
finland into nato is going to reduce the
possibility of some conflict with russia
some it's very hard to stand alone
sometimes though
the the people who are seeing the future
for
what it means to be a conservative what
it means to be a republican
i don't i don't know that they're the
majority right now but when you look at
these
elected officials or even some of the
candidates who are saying things that
are a little out of the ordinary from
what we've heard for the last five or
ten years i think those are the people
who are who are
seeing what's really coming for the
future of conservatism i think those are
the people people like blake masters who
are saying things that while shocking
today
will be mainstream
in the conservative movement
in three years five years seven years
they will be mainstream or there just
won't be much of a conservative movement
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael noel show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.